no vieron a nuevamente gracias por esta
comunicación cuál era su situación
financiera antes de la pandemia y cómo
decidieron incursionar en youtube
buenas noches
yo tenía
el canal
verdad y mi hijo davi siento el mirar
los canales de youtube que ninguno
miraba educativo es algo fuera
desconocido para las personas
y nos decidimos enlazar e instalar
podemos sembrar en apartamentos en casas
para que ninguno nos vengamos a costas
nada de comer
qué harán con estos recursos obtenidos
de youtube cuáles son sus planes a
futuro
bueno pues con lo del canal de youtube
ya tenemos para la parte de nuestro
nuestro lote
por 33 de nosotros todos
he podido tenerle habitaciones adecuadas
a mis hijos para que tengan ellos para
poder dormir
como la situación de colombia de la vida
de campo
cómo está la situación en colombia de la
vida de campo
bueno pues el área del campo es muy
difícil los tropecientos
cultivan sus productos pero como
cultivan a ir a vender a estas
enfermedades y pueden terminar este es
el producto del campesino no para ganar
en tres destinos a mitad de mes entonces
prácticamente está ofreciendo estas
tiendas nosotros también estamos una
página en tiempo estado y vierte
nuestros amigos en las teles estamos
ayudando a vender a un precio estable y
sin intermediarios